ah well should we start this review
properly well I start now a little
background what the hell is that hey
have you ever had French bread know that
you won't understand French bread is
really good yeah it's unbelievable
yeah it's overrated there's a reason
they call it pain he did what
inexcusable in a time of rape and murder
bread stealing will not be tolerated
sorry it's just that weird thing right
you see all your videos and it's like
having right next day and I gotta tell
you is change the music world forever
and now he's part of me
yeah changed it from good to bad so
why'd you go ahead to that way I should
probably make it what you wrote do we we
can't have him in the review we think I
don't know that I can't they rid of him
he's like a musical Armageddon the one
at the event
Louie Louie are they even heard a thing
we can't have him in the revealed you
think I don't know that we'd have to get
rid of him
he's like a musical Armageddon the
musical or the event cute movie over
here I know her again the musical I
don't want to close my eyes we can't
have him to review you think I don't
know that we have to get rid of him it's
like a musical Armageddon the movie or
the review doesn't matter movie or the
affects you if I can't I say both of
these things we can't have him in the
review you think I don't know that we
have to get rid of him
he's like a musical Armageddon whatever
were you guys shooting and I buck it up
- you look adorable way possible
that's Colm Wilkinson yeah it can't be
why not I can actually understand him
well we told you so hard I don't know
just the thing I was gonna be like okay
we can't bow to anything you can say
yeah I can say hi those wine you know -
if I have you those bread who make
useful Eve that man alone he's a musical
treasure no no it works if I do it
what was it raised this yeah it's
usually you know the Tibet yeah it's
usually the other way around
do you know them yeah bottom I am very
bad a hole up well maybe he got help
from his his sister it's not really seen
in this film or the child or the child
or the child you he or she may have
grown up to be come president whatever
that you do has anyone here read the
book have you read the book
no yeah how does not have had that
amount of wealth that fast no idea cuz I
read it over ten years okay so you ready
you just don't remember I said oh you
wrenched oh so it's like retranslated
okay so come Valjean into well how did
he know I was trying to save in bad
frames like outside in bad French now
you said that really bad thing just FF
rent at bad English really want you to
be in character so that would require
you going to medical school you blew my
mind that it would be better if you
could actually yeah
uh-huh oh and if anyone tells you I need
edible how about the da ba ha uh uh
awesome
I'll see you guys in a few days so
Javert has transformed into an evil
Captain Crunch which the stress at ran
because now that we have the Captain
Crunch hat
that's it Glenna it is a funnier it's
been redundant them know if we see if
we've seen brentalfloss first Napoleon
bored apart
Napoleon blown apart no no no like you
blew the part but that's not straight
from a mouse Russell yeah bill really
gives you a mouthful Maximus Bonaparte
Maximus but I was a bit Mayor McCheese I
don't think he had a big hat just had a
big head burger head you know that's
spending 10 minutes on yeah I don't
think I want a burger
I like Maximus Bonaparte okay cool it
could always tell you if you think about
if you think about our line better we
can always definitely this is only the
audio Admiral Crowe a she Oh Nelson sure
I don't know you're thinking about that
for a while or I don't know it's like
two weeks later in college I was like oh
my god
next to Valjean did this never know for
Olien Bonaparte oh my god just email a
to e or sucks
we're right here we have the mic right
here we can do but chromium problem dad
you know it is pretty fucking well in
observation Oscar page oh you have to
even get down there it's funny at second
use before I don't know that's a great
term it'll be like an actual sigh like
some shirkuh no no no it has like a real
war inside you know that's the internet
some was just like you know what I wanna
fuck Oscar oh I see him naked even
though he's kind of naked I wanted to
have junk oh I
I'll trash Justin your you are so short
oh well it's the Bell and your office -
okay it's like this a little bit wrong
you're pretty
hey driver separating - I'm separating
into okay I think : Louis
hello hi camera are you doing is it okay
if he gets food before he comes up well
of course all you have it's fucking
fingers I gotta have my chicken that's a
yes yes as long as this chicken fingers
I look my precious pictures as a
Skeletor dare you do a musical review
without me don't you know my angelic
voice can only be contained for so long
sheesh sheesh don't you want to know
okay if you're going to insult me don't
do it in song I don't know my line oh my
god you go
hm think I'll be okay oh he'll be fine
I'm just sure I get over it it's just
stare blankly the camera
unlike pardhu goons Muppets Scrooge 1 I
critique Anne Hathaway I lost a dad I
quit I did it again I dreamed I do it a
1/4 take perfect film well Russell
Crowe's I completely fucked up
so Valjean comes across Fantine looking
radiant in her Smeagol makeup
nevertheless Valjean does feel guilty
and takes her to the hospital where she
tells him that she has a child who needs
to be taken care of in case she dies oh
that old story her that before did you
don't touch me oh god are they raping
Santa when wouldn't that tenth levy para
noel is is always called in France him
oh ok uh you're going saving will para
Noel is French for father Christmas so
hope you kind of write what people
understand paranoia yeah says a mile you
have no choice I'm trying to avoid
comments if I say father Christmas every
one of the world's gonna say paranoia we
know just the French this is yeah what
we have we have French people on the
side we have a friend okay look they say
Santa in the movie anyway okay but
that's a good point actually I haven't
seen the movie but if that's true then
that's a good point cute okay I'll shut
up
wouldn't that technically be father
Christmas oh now you try cell phone yeah
whatever it is how about Christmas
wouldn't that technically be father
Christmas Hey you mean para Noel you
utter utter asshole totally do it
fuck you cares they're raping Pere Noel
I feel really bad I go away that mm-hmm
that does not see only every zone nice
save ratio you may not sing like that
there's a bright no hey there's a bright
golden haze on the weather I'm better
you're worried I have to go
that's your concerned about getting
caught are you yeah Schmidt's young we
have to you mean not saying like this
exactly do show friends I just said that
for the camera you get your hands off
the right now
and that was Linda's arad man they had a
lot of story packed in there but for the
most part I thought you got pretty good
I mean they had to really fit a lot and
I thought that you know when Paul
finally interrupts me that maybe we can
get the line going but he's just gonna
stand there smiling like an asshole
because that's what he does he's got
chickens watching and he's gonna yawn
and he's just a big douche that way and
now he's gonna go he's gonna have some
water I'm gonna have that water you
messed up the line you motherfucking oh
this is go yeah like okay I quit
God Connor well leave it they do also
while throwing in Marius SEPA dying of
rolls Chanel dress that's how I it's
pronounced paranormal huh what an
asshole
cock blocker cock blocker cock blocker
god blocker okay hot pockets
Oh wider than a mile high enjoy the
cinematography and pull has a light oh I
was gonna do girl power
vampires good not dude here the camera
that's so severe that's
- oh sure bear oh okay
that's worse than Crone apart as the
song is supposed to be sung quietly in
soothing here he belts it out I'm
surprised he doesn't wake up the entire
army Paul I will take your hands off of
her papa
I'm not doing nothing just it's still
better than Jackman I wanted to say my
fish line shit you're mad Oh bite me
grizzly beard try one without the Oh
bite me grizzly beard name a body part
look out radioactive man really I'm
really that's the best sound of picking
come up with that that's that that sound
effect in there on the Titanic the boat
rocks the other way and I didn't that I
did it so won't you do this I would like
to take this out and make like bits of
music you like a jingle bells dogs yeah
probably just idea a sample dancing I'm
good our team will so final thoughts on
the movie well I think it's great oh
yeah okay darn I done great
bring me my whittling horn well I think
it's terrible what the fuck am i doing
doesn't like it at all the reason I keep
foam bands cause it's like the only
motion I could do here I can't really do
anything as I I fall back look intrude
hey hey you guys were right I got a
whole my medical training in one day I
did become a doctor fuck fuck fuck fuck
go in the middle of the day no this is
your sister yoga shoot film magic will
sing like Russell Crowe who bows there
go one hello hello